i mean
all right people we're back in business
i'm dave rubin i'm wearing my florida
best it's may 23 2022 i am back in the
free state of florida after being on the
road
meeting
and hugging you good people
performing telling jokes telling stories
high fiving uh it was great
being back out on the road promoting the
book and just
you know seeing a little americana it
really was absolutely wonderful but i
have to tell you i seriously missed
being in the studio if i've learned
anything over the last
say month and a half since this book
came out and i've been on tour uh every
day that i'm not in here i i miss it and
i suppose that is a sign of uh doing
what i'm supposed to be doing for a
living and many of you would say to me
when i would do the meet and greet after
the shows people would be saying dave uh
i'm happy to see you here but i miss you
on the show oh you're getting the real
thing right now you're literally holding
my hand you're hugging me as you're
saying this isn't this better than
seeing me on youtube and they would
usually agree um
but i really missed being here and
obviously the world did not get any more
sane
since i was gone although there are some
signs of sanity and i think some good
things are happening and that was the
feeling throughout the tour uh so that's
what we're going to be talking about
today that there are some moves that
i've been talking about for about a
month you may remember about six weeks
ago i said we are entering the post woke
world and i think there are some markers
there to prove it uh real quick uh i
thought we'd just give you a quick
little maybe minute and a half recap of
a little bit of the tour this is uh
walking on stage in phoenix arizona
charlie kirk brought me on
[Applause]
[Music]
just really great crowds everywhere
every single show on this leg of the
shore uh sold out there was standing
room only sometimes people couldn't even
get in we got a couple images just
because these theaters were awesome this
is i believe this was in this was the
last one this is denver right there it
was just a great great theater this was
arizona that's the video you just saw
there's a still from arizona and uh this
was san jose which i'll talk about san
jose in just a moment this might have
been the best show of the entire tour
douglas murray opened for me there and i
think we have one more uh that is in
oxnard if i'm not mistaken where uh
larry elder joined me and it was just
great and uh
now you're on tour you're having a great
time the book crush like
sold out shows like it was really
awesome and uh michael came on tour with
me and my buddy john uh was my tour
manager so we just had to we just had an
absolute ball we we ate good food and i
took naps people kept saying to me
aren't you tired aren't you tired doing
all these shows bouncing around all the
flights and everything like i sleep on
the plane like you know we eat right
like i'm trying to exercise i'm feeling
pretty good i think i might have lost a
little weight like it's all good but we
did have to go
to california and i have to tell you
that when you tour across the state
across the country uh especially now
especially in this postcovered world
that we're in you really really can see
the difference between the states so
like when i was in dallas a couple weeks
ago dallas
it's a red city in a red state and it's
pretty clean and decent and the crowd
was great but the crowd's not hysterical
because they don't need me in that crazy
way right because they're not refugees
there they're the majority there because
it's pretty much going okay
in texas much like when i did the shows
here in florida the crowds were freaking
amazing absolutely amazing but there
isn't like this feeling in the crowd of
oh my god i'm sitting with other sane
people i don't know other sane people
but when we did the shows in cali
there was definitely this feeling of
these were refugees these were the few
remaining sane people in whatever city
it might be in we were in brea which
orange county is a little bit saner and
it was an awesome show there and i met a
ton of community members by the way then
we were in oxnard and we were in san
jose but anyway we're in we're in
hollywood
and uh you know it's now that i live
here in florida what i see mostly on the
streets i see iguanas i'm going to see
the gator every now and again i see a
lot of peacocks snakes
lizards all over the place it's very
different as to what you see in
hollywood and i took some videotape
hollywood
hollywood
foreign
[Laughter]
hollywood
that's just a small compilation of
videos i mean hollywood los angeles is
an ab
salute
dump and you know what you guys deserve
it i tried larry elder tried uh this is
what you people want it's disgusting we
went to santa monica we had one off day
uh so we went to santa monica which we
thought it's on the beach i remember
santa monica the famous santa monica
pier that's where forrest gump ran to at
the end with all the people we thought
we'd go there and michael give me a word
how would you describe santa monica
michael
trashy
it was disgusting the whole place smells
like pee we had an ongoing debate
whether it smelled more like pee or more
like a urinal cake uh you know the
urinal cake that's supposed to clean up
the smell of pee when you pee like at an
airport they've got the urinal cake it
was a combination of just pure
disgusting homeless urine and the urinal
cake everywhere stinks there's garbage
everywhere it's filthy the everything is
disgust it's just horrible and it should
be one of the most beautiful places when
i got to la
uh you know eight years ago santa monica
was one of the most gorgeous places
that's where you wanted to live santa
monica oh by the way i will be throwing
some cash in the the cali jar since i'm
doing this but i also wanted to show you
something else just to show you how what
is going on the fundamental difference
between blue states and red states these
high tax high regulated states well what
happens i go out with john my buddy for
lunch
and uh you know it's early but we were
having some margaritas you know we've
been working hard you got to work hard
and play hard and i tweeted this out
because uh there was a three percent
kitchen fee on the bill and first off
yes 49 for a margarita pitcher is
absolutely insane so let's just put the
prices aside for the moment but then a
kitchen fee of three percent because
where else
were they gonna make the food were they
gonna do it in the bathroom as i tweeted
out uh does french laundry have this
kitchen fee gavin newsom it's just
insane but these people need to keep
charging more and more because there's
such a depressed economy there uh that
the they need to stay in business
somehow they need people to show up to
work nobody wants to work i mean it's
just like an endless cascade of problems
so in many ways it was very confirming
of my life decisions over the last six
months getting out of that dump and
moving to this wonderful wonderful place
and yes it's it's uh may now in florida
it's warm it's warm did you guys it was
warm this morning coming into work right
but it's okay we're free we're free
people look at the price of gas in la i
snapped this picture as we were driving
towards santa monica
669 689 709 7
23 absolutely
insane absolutely insane and it's never
going to stop they just want more that
being said i just want to say to all of
you who i met in brea to all of you who
i met in oxnard to those of you i met in
san jose and san jose was also
discussing the show is amazing amazing
probably the best show i've ever put on
but the city i mean just absolute trash
and homeless people i mean the amount of
people just running around screaming
like crazy homeless people screaming
random stuff
like bloody and drugs everywhere it's
like a democrat party convention it's
just
terrible but speaking of not terrible
there's a segue for you reminder guys
there's a couple seats left i'm going to
be in orlando the home of the once great
walt disney company with this guy ron
desantis who is keeping florida florida
june 2nd at the plaza live you can go to
daverubin.com
events to get your tickets and by the
way reuben report community members over
there on locals i'm hosting a breakfast
for people it's on me breakfast is on me
for all paying members
and you can have your eggs you can have
your oatmeal you can have yogurt
with coffee juice the whole thing i'm
paying for all of it and i'm looking
forward to seeing you guys all right we
got a big show for you uh before i get
to that i want to talk to you guys real
quick about relief band you know is joe
biden in the democrats disastrous policy
making you nauseous did you know that
one out of three americans regularly
suffer from nausea i hate to say it but
i'm getting older it's true and whether
it's taking a road trip riding a roller
coaster or even side effects from
medications you're just wandering around
santa monica nausea is becoming a
regular part of life if nausea is
getting in the way of enjoying life's
important moments i've got good news
you've got to check out relief band
relief band's the number one fda cleared
anti-nausea wristband that has been
clinically proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea and vomiting
associated with motion sickness anxiety
migraines hangovers morning sickness
chemotherapy and so much more how it
works is relief man stimulates a nerve
in the wrist that travels to the part of
the brain that controls nausea then it
blocks the signals that your brain is
sending to your stomach telling you that
you're sick it's like the name says it's
legitimately a ban that you wear on your
wrist to give you relief from nausea and
anxiety and you can change the intensity
depending on how you're feeling to make
it stronger or weaker it's that simple
the technology was originally developed
over 20 years ago in hospitals to
relieve nausea from patients but now
through relief band it's available to
the masses plus it's 100 drug free
non-drowsy and provides all-natural
long-lasting relief with zero side
effects for as long as needed
and they've just released their newest
model relief band sport the sport is
waterproof has extended battery life and
can even attach to your apple or android
android watch don't let the fear of
nausea prevent you from being present
for life's important moments right now
you can join over 100 000 relief band
users with an exclusive offer if you go
to reliefband.com and use promo code
ruben you'll receive 20 off plus free
shipping and a no questions asked 30 day
money back guarantee remember it's
better to have a relief band and not
need it than to need it and not have it
so head on over to reliefbnd.com
and use my promo code ruben for 20 off
plus free shipping shipping shipping and
now back to me all right so
as was the theme with the tour and i
could feel it in the crowd
it's starting to turn the post woke
world is here people are starting to
feel juiced up there's a feeling like we
can win it doesn't mean they're going to
stop because they ain't going to stop
the woke it's a cult it's a zombie
brain eating disease they are going to
keep moving but there are signs that we
can start winning lots of signs that we
can start winning and one of them
has been what's going on for the last
you know five or six weeks which is that
elon musk is starting to get in the game
right it's not just that the guys you
know creating electric cars with tesla
and sending rockets with spacex and
doing neuro-link and building tunnels
under california and all of that stuff
he also decided to buy twitter which now
is a little up in the air because it
turns out that uh well now it seems like
20
of twitter's accounts may be fake if not
more
but then
over the last couple days and i'm sure
some of you saw this already but we're
recapping some of the stuff that i
missed uh elon musk was a guest uh
digitally at the all in podcast the
all-in podcast convention was here in
miami a couple days ago uh one of the
hosts is david sacks my friend and one
was one of our investors and locals uh
and elon skyped in
to talk about how he's gonna vote for
republicans whoa
the reality is uh that twitter at this
point you know has a very far left bias
um and i i would class myself as a
moderate and you need neither the
republican or nor democrat um and in
fact uh i have voted vote overwhelmingly
for democrats uh historically
overwhelmingly like i'm not sure
i might never have voted for a
republican just to be clear right now
now this election i would
wow
david you okay
keep going keep going he's fine he's
fine we're going to resuscitate him
we're going to resuscitate david sacks i
mean
let me ask you a personal point i'm
trying to make is that this is not some
sort of attempt to uh you know it's not
some right wing takeover uh as as say
people in life may fear but rather a
moderate wing takeover
okay
i gotta say
i'm feeling
somewhat validated at the moment what i
have been screaming about for about
seven years is that there has been
something very very wrong with the
democrat party there has been something
wrong with liberalism progressivism saw
that soft underbelly of tolerance and
brought in communism and marxism and
collectivism and destroyed whatever
moderate version of liberalism existed
the liberals of the 60s of the 70s the
aclu john f kennedy jr et cetera et
cetera they simply do not exist and yes
there are five of them there is bill
maher who just two years after getting
everything wrong suddenly sounds sane
always uh there's a couple others okay
it doesn't mean that your aunt isn't an
old school liberal but in terms of the
machinery of it
this is what i've been saying forever
and in essence this is now what elon
musk has come to so this is a it's not
just i don't mean to make this about me
actually in many ways i i would much
prefer to make this about you because i
know especially having been on the road
for the last couple weeks meeting so
many of you how many of you
come up to me during the meet and greets
and would say dave i was a lefty too
dave i was a liberal too
and it doesn't mean as as he said you're
somehow an ideologue now right like this
is a guy who considers himself a
moderate the moderate positions of free
speech of open inquiry of of competition
all of those things of not hating
america these are now republican
positions so here's a guy who does not
even know if he has ever voted for a
republican saying that you have to vote
for republicans and it reminds me of a
line that some guy has been saying for a
while who's that guy oh that guy's me
that you don't have to be a republican
but you cannot be a democrat if you want
america to continue if you want any of
the goodness of freedom to continue any
of the things that our forefathers that
our grandparents our founding fathers
fought for you cannot be a democrat they
are here now to destroy the country and
elon gets it and i can tell you that as
the why i left the left guy and as
someone that has written a couple books
about this and does this show like
man
it's nice being a little early to the
party i suppose and if elon is now about
to mainstream the thing that i have been
screaming about for a long long time
that is pretty freaking great he
continued on twitter about this he wrote
in the past i voted democrat because
they were mostly
the kindness party but they have become
the party of division and hate so i can
no longer support them and will vote
republican now watch their dirty tricks
campaign against me unfold so there's a
couple interesting things there because
the idea that they were mostly the good
guys the democrats all these years the
more i talk to conservatives the more i
talk to you know these scary people like
dennis prager who joined me in brea or
larry elder who joined me in oxnard
uh glenn beck and all of the rest of
these guys um they've been fighting for
these things for a long time and it was
just i don't know that it's that the
democrats were ever really the nice guys
i think they were many many many of them
were were misguided right they were they
were misguided they thought big
government policies worked maybe there
was a time when a functional government
could do some good things i think that
time is long gone uh but you guys all
know where the road to hell uh what it's
led with which is good intentions right
um
so there's something really nice
happening here he's getting it and then
of course he's also kind of teasing out
hey now watch what they're gonna do to
me and i thought that was interesting
because you guys know this those of us
that have been fighting
this woke insanity for years right
whether it's me or jordan peterson or
ben shapiro it doesn't even matter
whether you're old school liberal or
conservative whatever
look at the way the mainstream media has
treated us right i mean my picture was
on the front of the sunday new york
times saying got me and jordan peterson
and milton friedman and ben shapiro were
the leaders of the alt-right
so he knows what the machine is going to
do to him and he's saying i'm still
going to do it and again that's why this
thing is so cool he does not have to do
this he has more money than anybody he
could leave earth forever
but why
did i leave the left
why is elon leaving the left because
something ain't right and he continued
on twitter because he's warning people
that the machine does some bad stuff
when you don't behave he said the
attacks against me should be viewed
through a political lens this is their
standard despicable playbook but nothing
will deter me from fighting for a good
future and your right to free speech so
again this is beautiful now as i said
earlier this situation with twitter is
very up in the air right now because
originally they thought when he decided
to buy twitter they thought that around
five percent of twitter's accounts were
fake meaning that they were bots
or their burner accounts by people
they're just not real accounts now it's
looking like it might be 20 and there's
rumors that it might even be more than
that
so they have to decide he has to decide
do you want this deal to go through he
was paying this crazy premium right 40
something billion dollars for this
company that doesn't make a lot of rev
that isn't doing that well but he was
doing it for the fight for free speech
now he's finding out that a huge amount
of this company's traction the retweets
the clicks the likes all the stuff that
it's absolutely fake but what he's
saying here here is i'm going to fight
i'm going to fight for free speech i'm
going to fight the establishment i'm
going to fight
this left-wing nonsense and if you are
still not convinced that this guy wants
to fight well then he did this which
probably will get him killed he tweeted
about hillary clinton and you can't do
that he was responding to jim jordan and
he wrote all true bet most people still
don't know that a clinton campaign
lawyer using campaign funds created an
elaborate hoax about trump and russia
makes you wonder what else is fake do
you guys realize this it is now bubbling
up into the mainstream the thing that
most of us have known for years hillary
basically faked the dossier robbie mook
who worked for her just testified in the
last couple days that hillary basically
knew that the thing was fake and they
just passed it off to the media and then
hillary even tweeted out from about five
years ago when she was running for
president she even tweeted out a press
release talking about russia collusion
and she pretty much knew it was all made
up and the media just ran with it so
when you add all these things up that
the media runs with lies that then the
clicks and the likes and the retweets
that they're all fake all of this stuff
it kind of adds up to why everything has
felt so crazy because there's been a
certain set of us that have been
fighting for something true that have
been trying not to be completely
manipulated and have our whole world
view shaped by what trump says or
doesn't say and it's been hard to stay
sane throughout that throw in covid and
you know ukraine war and blah blah blah
all the stuff um
and that leads me to
where most of you guys when you were
saying hi to me at these shows
they would give me the one second hug
sometimes the husband would forego his
hug or the wife or go her hug so that
the spouse could give me a two second
hug i would not allow for the three
second hug but what people would always
say to me is dave thank you for keeping
me sane over these last couple years and
i think sanity's starting to scale it's
starting to go viral like he's given us
room to be sane and there's something
very cool here and it's happening not
only through him now exposing hillary
clinton and as i said it usually doesn't
go well for people that expose hillary
but i'm gonna go on the train too uh but
there's a bunch of companies now hulu
netflix and war that are are turning
against the woke we'll talk about that
in just a sec i want to talk to you guys
about upside real quick you know from
cringing at the pump to getting an
eye-popping check at your favorite
restaurant inflation is hitting us where
it hurts and it really hurts that's why
i started using upside upside's an
incredible app for anyone who buys gas
groceries or dines out with every
purchase i'm earning cash back thanks to
upside it helps me out all the time in
comparison to credit card rewards or
loyalty programs you can earn three
times three times more cash back with
upside you can cash out any time to your
bank account paypal or an e-gift card
for amazon and other brands upside users
are earning more than a million dollars
every week that's probably why they have
4.8 star
ratings on the app store to get started
download the free upside app in the app
store or google play use my promo code
ruben and get five dollars or more cash
back on your first purchase at 10 bucks
or more next claim an offer for whatever
you're buying on upside check in at the
business pay as usual with a credit card
or debit card and get paid download the
free upside app and use promo code ruben
to get five dollars or more cash back on
your first purchase of ten dollars or
more that's five or more cash back on
your first purchase of ten dollars more
using promo code ruben
and now back to me okay so now let's
continue elon musk starts not only
defending free speech saying hey you got
to start voting for republicans this is
kind of giving room this is giving room
for other people perhaps other
influential people in the tech world to
say it's okay to vote republican by the
way when he said that the reason that
they flashed uh that was the the hosts
of the all-in podcast all four of the
guys that host the show there when when
they flashed and you can see one of the
guys touching uh david sacks his face
it's because david sacks has been out
there voting for republicans he's been
the one that's been ahead taking the
unpopular position because it's been the
right thing to do for quite some time
they were sort of being like oh elon
hasn't been going the way you are but
now he's coming around it's a beautiful
thing but it's not just that elon is
fighting for free speech he's now going
after hillary and exposing all of this
crazy russia collusion remember for four
years we were told that russia installed
donald trump we had a sham impeachment
about it and now it's turning out they
made up the whole thing well i shouldn't
say now it's turning out we've known it
for quite some time but now it's going
mainstream thanks to elon musk we've got
some info here from the daily wire tesla
ceo elon musk ripped former secretary of
state hillary clinton on friday after
testimony in the criminal trial of her
former campaign attorney revealed that
she approved pushing unfounded claims of
trump-russia collusion to reporters on
friday he responded to an account
flagging a 2016 clinton tweet on false
trump russia collusion claims as
disinformation you are absolutely
correct that tweet is a clinton campaign
hoax for which their campaign lawyer is
undergoing a criminal trial musk said
referring to the trial of cyber security
attorney michael sussman that began in
washington dc on monday in a follow-up
tweet musk challenged twitter ceo parag
agrawal and twitter general counsel
vijayagaday over the false
2016-16 claim
what say you must ask the tesla ceo has
been an outspoken critic of twitter's
censorship policies throughout
negotiations so this is seriously
interesting stuff we know that twitter
as a company not only did they boot
trump after january 6th but they were
censoring things related to the biden
laptop uh when other people were saying
that hillary clinton was uh spreading
this misinformation and making up the
russia stuff and the dossier all of the
stuff that you guys all kind of know
right that they don't cover on
mainstream
we know that they were shadow banning
tweets they were not letting you share
certain links and everything now it's
all coming out and this is all good
sunlight is the best disinfectant and
what's happening is now that it's all
coming out now that we're realizing the
numbers were fake and the media lies
about everything well now even the
corporations are starting to turn around
as you know disney has lost
41 billion dollars
in the last six weeks because they
fought with ron desantis so he said woke
not going to take it anymore they lost
41 million well now
hulu uh is turning against hillary as
well it's happening it's happening right
in front of our bases we got some more
info from the daily wire hillary clinton
took another loss as hulu has passed on
a show about her that had been in
development at the network for nearly
two years rodham is based on the novel
of the same name which tells the story
of an alternate universe in which
hillary does not marry bill clinton but
instead serves as a northwestern
university professor before running for
president in 2016. first off that sounds
like literally the worst thing i've ever
heard in my entire life the fact that
that was in development for two years
all of those people should be fired and
shamed forever a fictitious hillary
clinton she didn't marry bill and blah
blah blah okay just terrible but
something good is happening here right
we're watching disney collapse and now
suddenly hulu
which every time you open up hulu it
tells you black history month analogy bt
shows and all of this stuff now they're
going oh wait a minute maybe this
hillary stuff ain't working maybe some
of this woke stuff ain't working and
there's more it's not just hulu netflix
even has joined the parade against the
woke we've got more info from the daily
wire a new corporate culture memo from
netflix is taking a hard-line stance on
attempts to silence artistic
expression by warning those who are
offended by the streaming services
content that they may want to go find a
job somewhere else variety reports that
the change in netflix's company culture
appears to be in large part due to the
backlash the streaming service faced
from woke employees last year over its
dave chappelle special which the
employees claimed was transphobic the
updated netflix culture memo includes a
new section called artistic expression
that states it will not censor specific
artists or voices even if employees
consider the content harmful if you'd
find it hard to support our content
breath netflix may not be the best place
for you the memo states later adding
that employees may be required to work
on projects that they perceive to be
harmful and that if they have a hard
time accepting their work assignment
they might want to consider working
somewhere else well hot diggity dog
you're going to make people do the job
you hired them for that is completely
bananas huh i mean really it's happening
do you see it's happening these
companies which have capitulated to a
bunch of purple haired freaks are
finally saying enough is enough netflix
stock has taken taken a crazy crazy dive
uh 72
down over the last six months so do you
think that maybe over there they're
going boy guys you know we've been doing
all this woke programming and sure it
all sucks and we've ruined comedy and
there's nothing funny and people just
literally spend most of their time on
netflix trying to find things to watch
and they can't find anything and we've
got a bunch of these children working
for us that are boycotting us while
they're supposed to be at work and blah
blah blah
they've all become cult members
pretty good pretty good they're finally
pushing against it now i don't have any
great faith in netflix because it is
still run by this guy reed hastings and
reid hastings put millions and millions
of dollars into the campaign to keep
gavin newsom as governor of california
and and to he really horrible you may
have seen them last summer these ads
against larry elder basically calling
larry elder a white supremacist so that
was what the netflix ceo was doing uh
but they're also now axing woke programs
on netflix which is good now i'd like to
see if they can make some actual good
programs that would be nice so i have
something to watch besides seinfeld but
they're getting rid of the woke nonsense
a little more from dw
netflix has pulled the plug on dr ibram
x kennedy's show anti-racist baby along
with several other proposed offerings
that would present a nod or a total body
immersion experience to woke culture
according to a report from variety
candy's anti-racist baby which was aimed
at preschoolers was one of the animated
shows to get the acts the others were
the eva duvernay produced wings of fire
series and a film titled with kind
regards from kindergarten so do you see
what's happening here the corporations
because the people
this is because of you this isn't just
elon musk this isn't just because a few
of us
that are public people are standing up
it's because people are starting to vote
with their dollars disney plus is being
cancelled at record levels netflix stock
diving at record levels because people
are canceling at record levels it's all
happening right in front of us this
thing that we all knew was wrong
that was gross that was infecting
everything this woke virus this woke
disease it's being defeated as we speak
now give it its credit give the devil
it's due it morphs it changes
always the badness the ideas of
collectivism and and all of these things
they don't just go away but good things
are starting to happen and now it's even
leaking into some of the guys who have
been the bad guys for a bunch of time
jeff bezos now you know jeff bezos now i
like people who create things and i give
the guy a lot of credit okay the guy
created amazon uh he's he's done some
amazing amazing things
but now he is but he also created or
bought the washington post which is
complete democrat corporatist propaganda
but he's even coming around but before i
get to him i want to talk to you guys
about healthy cell real quick have you
ever wondered if those vitamins you're
taking every day are actually working
for you more than 240 million more than
240 million americans take supplements
daily in pill form but they usually
don't get the promised results because
they don't absorb the nutrients properly
what if i told you there's a new type of
dietary supplement one that will absorb
into your body far better i want to tell
you to check out healthy cell it's a new
ingestible gel that not only tastes
great but has 165 percent more
absorption than pills look i've got a
box of it here they come just like this
it's gel i had some this morning it uses
a new technology called microgel to
deliver maximum absorption absorption
those old-school fashion tablets
capsules and powders contain synthetic
other ingredients ever wonder what those
things are it's things like binding
glues fillers and coatings that can
irritate the lining of your stomach
healthy cells micro gel on the other
hand suspend soluble ultra absorbable
nutrient particles inside a natural gel
made of gut healthy ingredients like
soluble fiber citrus pectin acasia gum
and water it doesn't contain artificial
sweeteners flavorings or colorings heck
it's even non-gmo gluten free and
vegetarian visit healthycell.com that's
healthycell.com and use promo code ruben
for 20 off your first order and now back
to me okay so we're laying out a case
that's what we do here on the reuben
report program and as you can see some
good things are happening elon's
fighting netflix is coming around hulu
is coming around the culture the culture
war
is starting to move in our favor and
politics is downstream from culture so
there's big things on the horizon so
jeff bezos now jeff bezos i get it some
people like them some people don't
we all use amazon i try to use it less i
try to shop locally when i can but we
get it there's the convenience of the
app and stuff shows up to your door next
day or even same day sometimes
so he created this incredible
marketplace of amazon right he created
this thing where you could do crafts at
home and put it on the amazon
marketplace and they take a big cut of
it and sometimes then they create the
same product and put you out of business
but they give you a chance amazon okay
it is ubiquitous in society okay amazon
aws that basically runs the entire
internet although rumble we're coming
for you um
but he also is a guy who has bought the
washington post and the washington post
is a democrat paper it is leftist
propaganda and all that so i'm not
telling you that the guy is jesus i'm
just telling you that he's a powerful
influential guy and when they start
coming around that means some good
things are happening so here is a tweet
from joe biden he is the elderly man
pretending to be president and this is
what joe biden said he said you want to
bring down inflation let's make sure the
wealthiest corporations pay their fair
share now
before i show you jeff bezos's response
to this um i would just like to add my
opinion on this which is of course as
you know that's a completely nonsensical
thing his argument is if we only just
took more money from corporations that
we wouldn't have inflation that our debt
wouldn't be so high all of this nonsense
it's completely insane this is the same
guy who's just printing money by the way
while i was gone uh congress authorized
40 billion for ukraine i'm sure we'd
have no better use for that right
so they just print money endlessly and
then they blame the productive people
they blame the the tech people they
blame the corporate people people who
are making things uh for all of our
problems so jeff bezos saw this tweet
and he responded with this
he said the newly created disinformation
board should review this tweet or maybe
they need to form a new non-sequitur
board instead raising corporate taxes is
fine to discuss taming inflation is
critical to discuss mushing them
together is just misdirection now i
don't know that raising corporate taxes
is going to do anything the idea that if
we just took money from corporations and
i'm not saying all corporations are good
i'm not saying greed doesn't exist but
the idea that you just took more money
if the government just took more money
from corporations or people so it had
more money that it would do more good i
just think there's no evidence for that
but bezos was trying to be nice there
right he's trying to be magnanimous he's
trying to say okay we can maybe discuss
that
but he's saying his point is this has
nothing to do with inflation inflation
has everything to do with printing money
relentlessly inflation has everything to
do with all of the big government
programs that you morons
are constantly pushing and i also like
the fact that he poked at their
disinformation board right the
disinformation board which has been
suspended now which is a beautiful thing
so this is more winning right so the
corporations are turning against this
thing the disinformation board went away
the masks got taken off because of one
35-year-old judge in tampa about six
weeks ago
the dems are losing they are they are
losing right in front of our faces
they're losing the cultural institutions
and when you lose the cultural
institutions you start losing the
political war and that brings us to the
next part of this their losses are
mounting up and even
msnbc nbc washington post new york times
they can't ignore it because you can all
see it right in front of your eyes
here's nbc on what's going on with the
economy this morning america seems
trapped in a vortex of bad economic news
sky high food prices pump prices at
record levels soaring rents up 16 in one
year coveted lockdowns in china the
world's manufacturing center choking the
global supply chain u.s corporate
profits sinking russian oil under
partial embargo ukrainian wheat exports
at a standstill and all of it feeding
40-year high inflation that americans
are paying for every day on the front
lines shippers and truck drivers with
diesel fuel prices up 75 in one year in
indiana shelley conaway is a full-time
truck driver who also runs a charity to
rush supplies to those in need we were
looking at possibly buying trailers and
a truck
another truck but we won't be able to
afford to put tires on it or put fuel
all of it sending the stock market lower
the s p down 18 so far this year the
nasdaq down a stunning 27
okay
now first off i want to say i'm an
american
i love america i want america to do well
so i wish
that joe biden the elderly man
pretending to be president or the people
who are in charge of joe biden i wish
they were doing a better job but it
seems to me that either they are the
most inept people on earth or they're
intentionally trying to destroy the
country that is uh perhaps for a
different show or another time we can
debate that even further i'm starting to
think that's the case i don't think
people could be this inept i don't think
they could screw up everything so
profoundly uh what that woman said there
about the truck that she wanted to buy a
new truck now we know that you can
barely get trucks try to buy a car right
now it's extremely hard actually used
cars now are becoming more expensive
than new cars which is sort of
fascinating because at least you can get
an a used car so they're jacking up the
prices on used cars because people want
the immediate car right so that's one
thing you can't get new cars then they
jack up prices on all cars we all know
about the gas the fuel prices that she's
talking about and i can tell you this
actually uh in my house right now we
have about 15 workers here because we
are redoing a whole bunch of stuff right
now we got babies coming and we're
trying to baby-proof the house and get
nurseries in order and a whole bunch of
stuff we got painting and we're just
doing all sorts of stuff getting windows
in blah blah blah i can tell you that
everything is insanely expensive and
it's not just that it's insanely
expensive nothing shows up on time
nothing is available like it really
is crazy what's going on but you don't
even need me to tell you that because
you you know about it in your own life
uh and that then brings us to to really
something that there's no way i could
even think of a way to make this funny
or humorous but now we have a baby
formula shortage in the united states of
america we are the world's last
remaining superpower and maybe we ain't
that great at it right now i suppose
that if we get rid of biden and the
democrats we can get back to it um but
we have a baby
formula shortage in our country this is
not a third world country uh this is the
united states of america and it is
happening right now we've got more from
the daily wire parents face terrifying
baby formula shortage amid biden's
supply chain crisis parents are
frustrated and stressed while trying to
find infant formula for their children
as the shelves remain bare at popular
retailers including walmart target and
grocery store chains according to
shoppers many of these retailers have
instead
have instated limits on formula
purchases so even when their brand
becomes available moms can't stock up
most brands are sold out online or are
being offered by third-party sellers for
exorbitant prices shoppers have become
used to shortages on popular items in
grocery stores over the last two years
as supply chain issues persist a lack of
baby formula however creates a deeper
sense of urgency as parents become
increasingly frantic that they can't
feed their children i mean really think
about this i can tell you you guys know
we're having kids
so we have two babies coming i cannot
imagine literally cannot imagine what it
would be like if you could not feed your
infant and that is happening in the
united states of america right now
are we having hearings about it not that
i know of
the government joe biden is now
importing
importing formula from some countries in
europe and i think from mexico i've seen
all of these pictures in mexican
grocery stores they're completely
stocked up so biden's putting out these
pictures like oh look at these all this
formula we're bringing in from europe
and it's like is that a brag man is that
a brag that we can't get it right here
right
like they have screwed up everything and
as if you think they haven't infected
your kids with critical race theory and
if you think they haven't infected your
kids
with all of this gender nonsense now
they are literally starving babies
that is the biden administration that is
the ineptitude of the democrats right
now and everyone can see it
and that's why the first half of the
show was about people having enough
enough is enough
and it's coming out in the polling as
well uh cbs did a little piece on
minority polling and uh minorities don't
like joe biden you heard our cbs poll
democrats view the party is weak a large
number of them there's also such sharp
criticism of the president reacting too
slowly what's the signal here for
democrats
well the biggest one and you talked
about it with anthony with congressman
jeffries there the fact that young
voters black voters latino voters now
also are in agreement that the president
isn't necessarily doing enough to take
on the economic challenges and inflation
that's the secret sauce if you can't
convince young people black people
latino voters in this state like georgia
and others across the country you're
going to see democrats lose big
statewide elections
okay young people turning against the
democrats that's beautiful and that's
because of the culture stuff young
people generally are stupid we were all
young at one time and young people just
believe oh things are good and they're
always going to be good and if you say
you're going to help poor people and if
you just give money to things it'll kind
of work but the fact that young people
are waking up young people are going
something ain't right here is an
incredible sign
absolutely incredible sign the fact that
whatever sliver
of the woke people
is starting to not have the power over
everyone else is a beautiful thing then
you talk about black people black people
are fleeing the democrats now now uh
donald trump got something like eight
was what was the percentage that donald
trump got i think he got eight percent
of the black vote if i'm not mistaken in
the last election which was
significantly higher than before and i
think had it not been because of the
riots and the blm stuff that the
democrats did themselves i mean they
orchestrated it themselves had they not
done that i think he would have got much
higher but if more and more black people
are waking up and going boy you know
these big government programs don't do
anything they actually keep us in
perpetual um
in perpetual state of being unable to
take care of ourselves they lock people
into this government dependency and all
this stuff it's like that's good and if
latino people are going wait a minute
you know we came in here legally uh
we've been working hard we often take
some of the jobs that nobody else wants
um and we work really hard for for our
life to make a better life for ourselves
ourselves and our family and we've
you know come here from all of these
different countries in south america and
wherever else
and we're not that thrilled that they're
just letting other people in because
that gives us a bad name well guess what
young people guess what black people
guess what latino people there is
nothing left for you in the democrat
party there is nothing left for anyone
in the democrat party unless you are a
rich elitist who loves the machine if
you love sucking off elitists you should
be a democrat but if you don't
you should probably at least vote for
republicans
and with that in mind fox news has some
new polling out about what's going on
with biden and hispanics it's super
interesting president biden's approval
rating among hispanic americans has
plummeted to 26 percent according to a
wednesday poll from quinnipiac
university biden is less popular among
hispanics than any other demographic
including age and gender the poll found
the same quinnipiac poll conducted last
year put hispanic support at biden at 55
percent biden has been consistently
hitting new lows new lows in the poll
for nearly a year
young americans and white men also have
low approvals for biden at 27 and 29
respectively the president's highest
approval ratings are among americans
older than 65 and black americans at 45
and 63 respectively black americans are
the only demographic in which biden has
a positive approval rating according to
the poll so first off let me talk about
that part
the 63 black approval rating for joe
biden to me is just because they have
confused people because of the lunatics
at msnbc and the crazy joy reads and the
endless screaming that somehow
republicans are racist if the democrat
policies of big government and handouts
and welfare and all of these things
worked then
why are people still in welfare why do
we have this generational stuff right
read a thomas all book you'll get it um
but they are losing and they are losing
terribly and they're fueling it
themselves
because they always double down
when is the last time you saw a liberal
or a democrat say boy maybe we're doing
some of this wrong maybe we should
rethink some of this stuff maybe not all
of our opponents are crazy racists maybe
some of our big government policies
maybe punishing people for success by
taking more of their money just so we
can put it into government programs that
don't really do anything maybe some of
this doesn't work and we should look in
the mirror for a second and come up with
better policies well they never do that
they always double down in this video
i'm about to show you this is from the
televised mental institution of msnbc uh
this is a guy by the name of donnie
douche and donnie douche great name like
this is the most on point name ever
donny douche over here he's a branding
expert and he is accepting on msnbc that
the democrats are getting slaughtered so
what does he say they have to do oh it's
just extraordinary enjoy
we don't have the economy on our side as
democrats so you have to scare the
bejesus out of people the way to scare
that is that you know this replacement
theory this is not just coming from some
dark corner of the web this is the
republican platform
do you see what donnie douche just said
on the television mental institution of
msnbc he said and this the clip goes on
and on i didn't want to belabor with you
because it's early in the day you're
trying to live a good life so i can't
have you watching too many of those
clips and i'm about to show you
something from the view so i'm just
trying to be respectful for you um
he's basically saying oh this
replacement theory we should run with
this this idea that you know that
republicans are all
they're afraid that white people are
going to be replaced blah blah blah he's
saying we can't win on the economy we
can't win on any of the real things so
we just have to label them racist he's
not saying that they're racist this is a
branding expert who was brought on to
explain what the democrats should do
it's very rare that they actually tell
you how calculatingly evil they are but
that's what donnie douche said right
there donnie douche she should have been
in the sopranos um and now a video i got
to do it i got to do it it's been a
while guys i haven't seen it in a while
uh this is sunny hostin sunny hostin is
a crazy racist woman who is just the
worst of the worst if you if you want to
find someone if you're not sure what you
think about the world right
if you just don't know what you think
about the world you don't have time to
watch dave reuben you don't have time to
you know really think things through you
should just watch clips of sunny hostin
and if sonny hostin says something if
you believe the reverse you'll be in
good shape i really believe that's a way
to live it's it's a way to live here's
sunny hostin trying to explain to us
that it's the democrats who are the
moderates they are playing to the base i
mean if you look at all the studies the
republican party has moved further to
the right than democrats have to the
left there's a pew research um center
analysis that finds that on average
democrats and republicans are farther
apart ideologically today than at any
time in the past fifty years and that
ideological divide breaks down to the
republican party being an extremist
party and this the democratic party
actually as you just mentioned sarah
moving more to the center but isn't the
problem that is the primaries because
you can't get through these primaries
unless you are extreme
okay she's she's just an idiot the pew
research that she uh quoted there has
nothing to do with what she said her
argument was that the republicans have
become
more extreme and then she's saying that
the parties the what the pew research
poll was about was that the parties have
moved far apart but it's not because the
republicans went crazy the republicans
you can argue have moderated in a
million different ways hey say gay
marriage for one that was a big one for
a long time right are there republicans
really screaming about gay marriage
anymore remember it was only six seven
eight years ago that the republicans ran
several candidates who were vehemently
against gay marriage right remember mike
huckabee remember rick santorum right
they all moved on that because of that
orange guy right who ran against who ran
for gay marriage you know he was for
same-sex marriage as a first-time
candidate unlike that barack obama guy
big homophobe that guy remember that um
so you could say that's one you could
also say that republicans even on
abortion
even on abortion are more moderate why
could you say that well here in a place
in a red state run by right-wing maniac
ron desantis we have a 15-week ban on
abortion that's three and a half months
that's a moderate position because
that's pro a pro-life state a
conservative state saying oh we will
compromise we are not going to try to
outlaw abortion all together we're not
even going to go for six weeks or 10
weeks or 12 weeks which i would be okay
with they're saying three and a half
freaking months and it passed just six
weeks ago and it goes into effect in
july that's a
moderate republican position what's the
democrat position on abortion well uh
just last week every single democrat
in the house voted that there should be
no limits on abortion ever yes
eight-month abortions eight-month
abortions so who is more moderate the
people that want to rip eight-month
babies out of the womb and murder them
or the people who are saying 15 week
abortions
on top of gay marriage and we could do a
whole bunch more on this stuff i think
you got my point guys it's monday and
that means that it's me monday over at
reubenreport.locals.com
here's the meme that i put up today
uh that is aoc and if you didn't hear it
this poor man that's next her that is
her soon-to-be husband they are getting
married that little soy boy right there
and i thought this was just perfect uh
they will be pregnant soon enough
obviously he will be the pregnant one
and there will be a little
baby karl marx coming out of his womb
because men can give birth and in this
case they will give birth to horrific
communists uh let's get some comments
from the locals community amy says ah
hollywood the place where dreams come
true as long as it's the dream of
homelessness and heroin i mean i'm not
kidding i took 20 videos like that
michael were you sick of me singing the
hollywood song by the end he could not
stand the hollywood
hollywood phoenix likes the song you
like the song you're from hollywood so
it has more meaning to you
um it was just disgusting what an
absolute dumb never go to santa monica
again it's it's it's just horrible it's
just even to go to bubba gum shrimp i
didn't go in but i just wanted to see
bubba gump shrimp i enjoyed the forest
gump and it was just like it's just
filth everywhere and drugs and it
smelled we took the picture out we were
going to include a picture of the show
at the hotel i stayed at there was a
huge warning outside the pool that if
you had diarrhea they didn't want you in
the pool and it's like who's going into
a pool with diarrhea but there they have
to tell you about it harris says if
you're still a democrat you are being
manipulated or worse you're a
manipulator yeah that's interesting
right like
a huge swath of people if you're still a
democrat at this point if you still
think that bernie sanders and elizabeth
warren and aoc if you still think these
are the good guys then you're either
completely manipulated in which case
there's some work maybe we can get some
of you guys right i was once there
as i just said i was on the road i met a
lot of people who said they were former
lefties like
you can you can get there but then or
you're the manipulator i like that
because then there's the set of people
who are the manipulators and why would
you be a manipulator for the democrats
it means you like power that is the only
thing they stand for they stand for more
money more power more control over you
and guess what they're going to bring
back lockdowns and they're going to
close your businesses again and they're
trying to get us into a war in ukraine i
mean they're trying to escalate the war
even new york times this past weekend
ran an op-ed by mitt romney basically
saying yeah nukes are coming like he's
and he's a democrat as far as i'm
concerned
we've got to get rid of these people we
just got to get rid of them anya says i
gave the tickets to my friends in san
jose and they absolutely loved the show
they had the vip tickets and they got a
hug wait so you didn't come to the show
what happened there anya did you not
come did you are you're busy what's
going on maybe you were cleaning up the
streets because san jose is a dump but
the show was amazing it was really my
favorite show can we show that theater
again connor can you pull that that san
jose theater up again for just one
second before we close out uh every show
as i said was sold out this is this is
the san jose improv it's just an awesome
you know comedy clubs usually don't look
like theaters like this they're usually
one level so it was just an awesome
awesome room douglas murray opened for
me and we have video by the way of that
and i think we're going to put together
a little a little stand-up special
that we're going to probably work around
the orlando show that we're doing with
ron desantis which by the way is on june
2nd in orlando you can get tickets at
daverubin.com
events there's a couple seats left if
you'd like to join me and the governor
and perhaps future president of the
united states i i don't know
what do you think i have some kind of
insider knowledge i have no idea
uh guys my full interview
with jack carr is up right now you can
get the whole thing on youtube rumble or
on locals and uh we've got a cold
clothes for you and i just want to say
it's been good being back here
i missed you guys i'm i know you missed
me uh and uh we're gonna win we're gonna
save the world and then and then we'll
rest how does that sound for a monday so
i will see you
tomorrow